so let's say that this is an equilateral
triangle and what i want to do is make
another shape out of this equilateral
triangle and i'm going to do that by
taking each of the sides of this
triangle and divide them into three
equal sections
into three equal sections so my
equilateral triangle wasn't drawn super
ideally but i think you'll get the point
and the middle section i want to
construct another equilateral triangle
so the middle section right over here i
am going to construct another
equilateral triangle
so it's going to look something like
this
and then right over here
i'm going to put another equilateral
triangle
and so now i went from that equilateral
triangle to something that's looking
like a star or a star of david and then
i'm going to do it again
so each of the sides now i'm going to
divide into three equal sides and that
middle segment i'm going to put an
equilateral triangle i am going to put
an equilateral triangle so in the middle
segment
i am going to put
an equilateral triangle so i'm going to
do it for every one of the sides so let
me do it
right there
and right there i think you get the idea
but i want to make it clear
so let me just so then like that
and then
look like that like that
and then almost done for this iteration
this pass
and it'll look like that but i can do it
again each of the segments i can divide
into three equal sides and draw another
equilateral triangle so i goes there
there there
there there i think you see where this
is going and i could keep going on
forever and forever
so what i want to do in this video is
think about what's going on here and
what i'm actually drawing if we just
keep on doing this forever and forever
every every s every iteration we look at
each side we divide into three equal
sides and then the next iteration or
three equal segments the next iteration
the middle segment we turn to another
equilateral triangle this shape that
we're describing right here is called a
coach
snowflake and i'm sure i'm
mispronouncing the coach part
the coach snowflake and was first
described by this gentleman right over
here who is a swedish mathematician
niels fabian helga von coach who i'm
sure i'm mispronouncing it and this is
one of the earliest described fractals
so this is a fractal and the reason why
it is considered a fractal is that it
looks the same or it looks very similar
on any scale you look at it so when you
look at it at this scale
so if you look at this it looks like you
see a bunch of triangles with some bumps
on it but then if you were to zoom in
right over there then you would still
see that same type of pattern and then
if you were to zoom in again you would
see it again and again so if fractional
is anything that on any scale and any
level of zoom it kind of looks roughly
the same so that's why it's called a
fractal now what's particularly
interesting and why i'm putting it at
this point in the geometry playlist is
that this actually has an infinite
perimeter if you were to keep doing it
if you actually make the coach snowflake
where you where you where you you keep
an infinite number of times on every
smaller little triangle here you keep
adding a another
equilateral triangle on its side and to
show that it has an infinite perimeter
let's just consider one side over here
so let's say that this side
so let's say we're starting right when
we start with that original triangle
that's that side and let's say it has
length s
and then we divide it into three equal
segments
we divide into three equal segments so
those are going to be s over 3
s over 3 which let me write it this way
s over three s over three and s over
three and the middle segment you make an
equilateral triangle
in the middle segment you make an
equilateral triangle so each of these
sides are going to be s over three
s over 3
s over 3. and now the the length of this
new part i can't call it a line anymore
because it has this bump in it the
length of this part right over here this
side now doesn't have just a length of s
it is now s over three times four before
it was s over three times three now you
have one two three four segments that
are s over three so now after one time
after one pace after one uh um time of
doing this this this adding triangles
our new side after we had that bump is
going to be four times s over three or
it equals four thirds s
so if our original true if our original
perimeter if our original perimeter when
it was just a triangle is p sub zero
after one pass after we add one set of
bumps then our perimeter is going to be
so it's going to be four
thirds times the original one because
each of the sides are going to be four
thirds bigger now so this was made up of
three sides now each of those sides are
going to be four thirds bigger so the
new perimeter is going to be four thirds
times that and then the then when you
take a second pass on it there's going
to be four thirds times this first pass
so every pass you take it's getting four
thirds bigger it's getting i guess a
third bigger on every it's getting four
thirds the orig the the previous pass
and so if you do that an infinite number
of times if you multiply any any number
by four thirds an infinite number of
times you're going to get an infinite
number of le infinite length so p
infinity
p infinity the perimeter if you do this
an infinite number of times is infinite
now that by itself is kind of cool just
to think about something that has an
infinite perimeter but what's even
neater is that it actually has a finite
area and when i say a finite area it
actually covers a bounded amount of
space that i could actually draw a shape
around this and this thing will never
expand beyond that and to think about it
i'm not going to do a really formal
proof just think about what happens on
any one of these sides
so on that first pass we have that this
triangle gets popped out
and then
if you think about it if you just draw
what happens the next iteration you draw
these two triangles right over there and
these two characters right over there
and then you put some triangles over
here and here and here and here and here
so on and so forth but notice you can
keep adding more and more you can add
essentially an infinite number of these
bumps but you're never going to go past
this original point and the same thing
is going to be true at this
on this side right over here it's also
going to be true on this side over here
also going to be true at this side over
here
also going to be true this side over
there and then also going to be true
that side over there so even if you do
this an infinite number of times this
shape this coach snowflake will never
have a larger area than this bounding
hexagon or which will never have a
larger area than a shape that looks
something like that i'm just kind of
drawing an arbitrary well i want to make
it outside of the hexagon i could put a
circle outside of it
so this thing i do in blue or this
hexagon i drew in magenta those clearly
have a fixed area and this coach
snowflake will always be bounded even
though you can add these bumps an
infinite number of times so a bunch of
really cool things here one it's a
fractal you can keep zooming in and and
it'll look the same the other thing
infinite infinite perimeter and and and
finite finite area now you might say
wait sal okay this is a very abstract
thing things like this don't actually
exist in the real world and there's a
fun thought of express a fun thought
experiment that people talk about in the
fractal world and that's finding the
perimeter of england or you can actually
do it with any island and so england
looks something like you know i'm not an
expert on it you know let's say it looks
something like that so at first you
might approximate the perimeter and you
might measure this distance
you might measure
you might measure this distance plus
this distance plus this distance plus
that distance plus that distance plus
that distance you're like look it has a
finite perimeter it clearly has a finite
area but you look look that has a finite
perimeter but you're like no way that's
not as good you have to approximate it a
little bit better than that instead of
doing it that rough you need to make a
bunch of smaller lines you need to make
a bunch of smaller lines so you can hug
the coast a little bit better
and you're like okay that's a much
better approximation but then let's say
you're at some piece of coast if we zoom
in if we zoom in enough if we zoom in
enough the actual coastline is going to
look something like this
the actual coastline will have all of
these little divots in it and
essentially when you did that first when
you did this pass you were just
measuring you were just measuring that
and you're like that's not the perimeter
of the cosine you're going to have to do
many many more sides you're going to do
something like this
you're going to have to do something
like this to actually get the perimeter
to actually get the perimeter of the
coastline and just like hey now that is
a good approximation for the perimeter
but if you were to zoom in on that part
of coastline even more it'll actually
turn out that it won't look exactly like
that it'll actually come in and out like
this maybe it'll look something like
that so instead of having these rough
lines that just measure it like that
you're going to say oh wait no i need to
go a little bit closer and hug it even
tighter and you can really keep on doing
that until you get to the actual atomic
level so the actual coastline of of of a
of an island or a continent or anything
is actually somewhat kind of fractalish
and it's some kind it is you can kind of
think it is having an almost infinite
perimeter obviously at some point you're
getting to kind of the atomic level so
it won't quite be the same but it's kind
of the same phenomenon it's interesting
thing to actually think about